documentaire sur deborah logan première
la maladie d'alzheimer ne concerne pas
qu'une seule personne
le but de ma thèse et de dire je
recommence des efforts si tu veux garder
la maison il faut faire des sacrifices
c'est toi qui me parle de sacrifices je
maman ils veulent faire un film sur moi
magnifique va très bien nous assisterons
à la dégradation physique et mentale de
ce sujet et nous filmerons cette
dégradation sur deux périodes d'un mois
chaque on va bien s'amuser ça serait
parfait
voyez vous je n'ai pas envie d'être
exploitée sarah a dit que deborah hay du
somnambule alors on va installer des
caméras de surveillance
marolles
ras
vous savez vous avez foutu ça crie trop
il y en allant faire du jardinage tout
seul en pleine nuit
non il s'agit pas de somnambulisme là
vous devriez venir voir ça il ya un vrai
souci docteur est ce que tu te souviens
d'un homme qui s'appelait henry
desjardins il a disparu il ya une
trentaine d'années j'ai essayé de te
laver dans la rivière cette fois la
notion de parasites spirituel a toujours
existé
du mois
elle va bourrer